ever since Donald Trump in the
Republican tax plan was passed we have
been speculating but also reporting on
who is actually going to have lower tax
liability in 2018 for the 2018 tax year
for which we are now starting to file
taxes who's going to pay more taxes
because the tax cuts as they are being
billed are mostly for corporations and
for rich people and middle-class
Americans are actually going to be sort
of split in terms of whether they pay
more or less in taxes for this current
taxi er that we are or the current year
for which we are paying which is 2018
and even if in the short term a lot of
those middle-class Americans have a
slight reduction in how much they pay in
taxes much of what impacts the middle
class in the bill is only temporary
compared to the permanent tax cuts for
corporations and for rich people so
there's a sort of a few different ways
in which middle-income people could
benefit from a tax cut plan if indeed it
is real so number one is you might just
get what we would call like a
straight-up tax cut at the end of the
year accounting for your withholdings
and your refund your total tax paid goes
down that would be a tax cut there are
other ways in which middle-income people
might benefit if you believe in
trickle-down economics you would believe
that by giving corporations and rich
people a tax cut it would filter down or
trickle down to middle-class Americans
either by seeing increased capital
investment in businesses or increased
hiring for businesses but we got a
report last week saying neither of those
things have happened and then there's
the just kind of vague we're all better
off when rich people in corporations
have more money which I don't even think
really warrants refuting at this point
because we're so passed beyond that
absolute and total nonsense but most
notable is are people getting tax
refunds or not in 2018 and the reality
is that there are now more and more
Trump voters tweeting what happened to
my tax refund now I'm gonna break down
whether the refund in and of itself
actually tells us what we need to know
about the tax cut plan hint it doesn't
but as some examples we've seen let's
look at some tweets from Trump voters
who are very very angry about how
they're actually being impacted by
Donald Trump's tax plan the first of
which is April Henderson saying we're
paying five thousand dollars more in
taxes for 2018 imagine our surprise we
voted for you Donald Trump we have
advocated for you I have lost lifelong
friends in support of you I am truly
disappointed not only have our taxes
increased but you've done nothing to fix
our health care another tweet just got
my tax returns completed for the first
time under the new tax law I'm
officially paying more in taxes so rich
people can pay less you're almost done
wiping out the middle class Donald Trump
and Republicans this one is on you I'd
vote for Hillary before I voted for you
again one other example Donald Trump I
trusted and voted for you now screwed by
you I fall just above a tax bracket I
don't get the $5,000 return I've gotten
in the last three years money my family
depends on to start us over I served my
country honorably I will not make the
same mistake twice very angry doesn't
appear to understand how marginal tax
rates work but okay and then lastly
Donald Trump just did my taxes and
thanks for increasing mine no change in
income and got back 400 less than last
year that campaign promise was one of
the only two reasons I voted for you
rethinking that decision now
so let's first remember that a lot of
these people are angry but they don't
necessarily understand how taxes work so
it's really really important I want to
give everybody all the information that
they need to figure this out the first
thing to understand is that your tax
refund doesn't tell you whether your
taxes went up or down some people
expected tax cuts some people got them
some people didn't get them but some
people just aren't realizing that the
refund amount doesn't actually tell you
whether you paid more or less in taxes
because there's a difference between
taxes withheld and taxes actually owed
you could have two years in a row where
you pay $10,000 in taxes
imagine that in the first year during
the year you have $12,000 withheld turns
out you only owe 10,000 in taxes so when
you file your taxes you get $2,000 back
great the next year you might owe you
might owe $10,000 but you only had 9000
withheld so when you do your taxes you
have to cut a check for $1000 in both
cases you paid $10,000 in taxes the
difference being in the first year you
over withheld in the second year you
under withheld so changes were made by
the tax law to withholdings and the idea
was to make the withholdings closer to
people's actual effective tax rates so
you reduced your withholding during the
year you get a smaller refund at the end
but that doesn't actually change the
amount of tax due so that's number one
some people just clearly don't get it
that your refund doesn't tell you
whether you owe more or less in taxes in
total but then let's get to some of the
reasons why people may actually have had
an increase in the 2018 tax year - the
amount of tax that's due number one
there is now a limit of $10,000 to
what's called the salt deduction the
salt deduction tells you how much income
how much money rather can you deduct in
state and local taxes and real estate
taxes that limit is now $10,000 so
imagine that you earn $75,000 in
Massachusetts which has a 5.3 percent
income tax that's three thousand nine
hundred and fifty dollars in
Massachusetts income tax that you pay
that eats up about 40% of your $10,000
salt deduction if you have a property
where your property taxes are for
example $7,000 you're only going to be
able to deduct six of those $7,000
because you will hit that $10,000 salt
deduction there are lots of people who
are seeing a slight increase to their
tax taxes paid because of that limit -
the salt deduction another issue the
personal exemption of
$4,000 per dependent was eliminated
there are people who will end up paying
more in taxes as a result of that there
are some limits to how much mortgage
interest you can deduct although that
really only impacts very big mortgages
that likely wouldn't be held by a lower
and middle-income individuals but what's
incredible about all of this is that
like with most tax plans some people pay
a little more some people pay a little
less in the middle class but the people
that are really benefitting are the very
wealthy people who are saving a median
of $60,000 in taxes there are very rich
people who are saving hundreds of
thousands of dollars in taxes or even
millions of dollars in taxes and so when
you zoom out the big picture is you've
got middle-income Americans tweeting to
trump about $500 one way or the other
not to belittle the importance of $500
to middle-income Americans but what is
going completely ignored by a lot of
people is that there is one class that
very very much benefits from this and it
is the very rich who had gigantic tax
cuts again one group getting an average
cut of $60,000 this is the red herring
this is how they win and the the only
question is will they hold him
accountable in 2020 because all of a
sudden they'll get back to Hispanic
people are dangerous and we need Bible
study in school let's vote Trump and
forget about the fact that he promised
the tax cut and maybe I didn't get one
so a combination of misunderstanding how
a lot of these tax cuts a tax provisions
work combined with cognitive dissonance
and a short political memory may make it
so that Donald Trump still gets
reelected in 2020 one of the day's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers
by things online which protects your
actual debit card so that it's not
spread all over the Internet and one of
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a David Pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy comm
icon I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy comm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link